[Musique]
il y a cinq ans, thanos a effacé la moitié de la
population de l'univers
mais les habitants de cette planète ont
ramené tout le monde en un claquement de doigt le
retour soudain de la population a
fourni l'énergie nécessaire
pour que l'émergence commence
combien de temps en avons-nous
sept  jours
[Musique]
nous sommes éternels
nous sommes venus ici il y a 7000 ans
[Musique]
pour protéger les humains des déviants
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas aidé à combattre thanos ou
n'importe quelle guerre toutes les autres choses terribles à
travers l'histoire que
nous étions  chargé de ne pas interférer dans
les conflits humains à moins que des déviants ne soient
impliqués
par qui
[Musique]
nous devons trouver les autres
je n'en ai pas vu certains depuis des
siècles
salut
bonjour voici à
quoi ressemble la fin du monde
au moins nous avons devant  sièges en rangée
tu sais ce qui n'a jamais sauvé la planète
tu es du sarcasme
nous aimons ces gens depuis le jour où
nous sommes arrivés
quand tu aimes quelque chose
[Musique]
tu le protèges
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu ne peux protéger
aucun d'eux
je  Je parie que vous avez construit la maison sûre parfaite
qu'est-ce que c'est même fait de vibranium
collection d'automne
ikea
vous